wenn du hast eine sehr genaue meinung
dazu dass diese idee muss jetzt in
berlin nicht stattfinden dürfen
ja ich kann das ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht ganz fassen ich kann nicht fassen
dass vokabular des berliner
innensenators
ich kann s isch halt es kaum für möglich
dass das gericht dem dem verbot auch
stadt geben kann um noch mal zu zitieren
die gebühr die die wird die worte des
innensenators von berlin
ich bin nicht bereit ein zweites mal hin
zu nehmen das hat er schon so ne demo
gegeben dass berlin als bühne für corona
leugner reichs bürger und
rechtsextremisten missbraucht wird so
rechtfertigt er innensenator geisel das
von ihm ausgesprochene verbot jetzt muss
man ganz klar sagen wir befinden uns
nicht in der ddr es überlegt obliegt
nicht der politik zu entscheiden welche
politische meinung ihnen genehm ist und
werden demnach demonstrieren gab es hat
ich darf ich daran erinnern noch vor
wenigen wochen black lips meter
demonstrationen gegeben so zu sozusagen
als sie als die korona lage noch sehr
viel bedrohlicher war als jetzt und da
wurde das von der politik sogar
gutgeheissen und bejubelt also dass das
geht nicht man kann sprache und denken
nicht blick nicht unseren politikern
sprache und denken nach ihrem geschmack
dann demonstrationen zu genehmigen und
oder zu verbieten das geht ein gerät
wurde hier in diesem fall aber gesagt
dass man durch die demonstration dies
bereits am ersten august gab weiß dass
sich genau diese menschen gruppe die
jetzt zu diesen demos kommen würde eben
nicht daran hält an die masten pflicht
die bei black live-demos dann zum
großteil eingehalten worden sind oder
bei anderen demonstration das sind
zumindest die argumente jetzt marco mehn
er sagt das ist nicht gegen die
versammlungsfreiheit sondern für das
infektionsschutzgesetz er möchte die
menschen damit schützen dass diese
demonstration jetzt nicht stattfinden
dürfen
zehntausende menschen ohne maske dicht
gedrängt sind bedrohlich da bin ich
vollkommen diese diese dieses argument
kann ich vollkommen nachvollziehen
selbstverständlich ist das eine ist das
eine gefahr aber die reine annahme dass
gegen regeln verstoßen wird rechtfertigt
kein verbot das ist dass wir haben jetzt
müssen sie mal ganz klar machen
wir haben
mit dem vielleicht wichtigsten
grundrecht zu tun dass unsere verfassung
ausgesprochen hat nämlich das recht auf
freie meinungsäußerung und das recht auf
demonstrieren ich muss daran auch
erinnern das ist für eine demokratie
nicht nur wichtig sondern unerlässlich
ist dass man sich mit dass man sich mit
meinungen von leuten auseinander setzen
die vielleicht vollkommen konträr sind
wo kommen wir denn hin wenn die politik
entscheidet welche den demonstrationen
ihn passen und nicht und sagen wir mal
sagen wir mal es ließe sich aus
gesundheitspolitischen gründen
rechtfertigen das bleibt immer noch die
frage warum wochen wurden dann die black
knights matter der demonstration so von
der politik so bejubelt aber dass man
das mal ausgeklammert
wir können wir können doch nicht wir
müssen doch sehen dass das nicht nur
politisch oder aus sachlichen gründen
eine entscheidung ist die problematisch
ist und es ist vor allem aus politischen
gründen vollkommen irrsinnig